[Music]
hello everyone
so we'll continue our discussion with
the mathematical preliminaries chapter
and just to point out here we have been
discussing in our previous part of the
lecture
uh on the rules of index notation and
plan was
that we would be applying these rules to
something which is very familiar to us
in the form of the
dot product so we continue our
discussions with dot product
but before we can actually launch into a
discussion of dot products and how
the index notation may be applied there
uh
we first take a look at the unit vectors
themselves
so we know for a fact that
if we have a unit vector like this
e1 and it is dotted
with itself we know very well
that this is equal to 1. now
i hope that none of you will be feeling
uncomfortable
with this kind of a notation for the
unit vectors
because uh most of you may be more
familiar
with the i hat j hat k hat notation
but uh this is exactly like that okay so
you may
uh for starting out purposes you may
think of
that e 1 hat is like the i hat and the e
2 hat is like the j hat and the e 3 hat
is like the k hat
but this is certainly more general and
we should we should
familiarize ourselves with this kind of
notation
further along if we take the
dot product of the e1 hat with the e2
head we know that this is equal to zero
all right similarly if we uh
if we proceed like this we will find
that uh e2 hat
dot e3 hat is equal to 0 and so on and
so forth and e3 hat
dot e3 hat is equal to 1
now if we want to represent all of this
information at one shot
we can write something like this that e
i
hat dotted with e j hat
that is equal to 1
if i is equal to j and
0 if i
is not equal to j so this is
this one statement encapsulates within
it
all the information present inside
whatever we had written in the
earlier step okay now this particular
statement
can be written in a further shorthand
notation
using something which is referred to as
the chronicle delta
so we write it like this that e i
hat dotted with e j hat is equal to
delta i j okay so this delta i j
is called the chronicle delta
okay now
[Music]
it is important to note that
despite what we had been discussing uh
in the previous part of the lecture so
if we go back quickly
to this previous page we had said that
the number of pre-induces denotes the
order of the tensor of that term
now that should not give us a wrong
impression
that here we have i uh
like i is one index and j is another
index
in total this entity has two free
indices
so this is a tensor of order two this is
wrong
okay that that impression would be
completely wrong because
you understand that the way that this
has been written
it is certainly not the pure index
notation form
okay it is not really the index notation
form
because in index notation you note that
the first rule was that we would not be
writing any
unit vectors and these themselves are
the unit vectors so this is certainly
not index notation
okay whatever it is it is not index
notation so the rest of the rules of the
index notation also does not apply to it
so this is just a shorthand way
of representing the various combinations
of the unit vectors that may appear
in this dot products okay however
what we have written here would be
immensely useful further along as you
will see
very clearly uh i'd also like to mention
uh here something
in reference to the very first page of
our discussions so if we go back
to our page one we had seen that in the
component notation
we had written our v vector refer to the
x 1 x 2 x 3 axis like this
and alternatively the same v vector
refer to the x 1 dash x 2 dash x 3 dash
axis in this particular form
we had written this using the summation
notation and that is
certainly the correct and the and the
very explicit way of
representing it but what is done
sometimes is that
this is further shortened
and written like this
so this is written as v i e i
hat and this is sometimes written as
v i dash e i
hat dash okay
now uh you may think that
okay what's the big deal here but uh
there is a little bit of a of an issue
that we must be
very careful about ratio is this you see
if you take a quick glance at it and
don't think about it too carefully
then it may appear it may appear to it
to you that okay here this
v i e i hat it is
uh it is uh
it is denoting this particular summation
right
there is no doubt about it so v 1 e 1
hat plus
v to e to that plus v three e three hat
so this
seems like we are using this kind of the
index
uh this rule of index notation that a
repeated index
indicates summation so what we had
written on the page 2
of our discussions in the in the
previous lecture
this is what it is showing us that
if we have a repeated index then it
implies summation
and it is certainly doing that in in
this particular case
now if we are following one of those
rules of index notation
then we would be very much
tempted to think of another rule of the
index notation which is that
the number of free indices denotes the
order of the tensor of that term
so my argument is like this that if we
are
using this rule number two of index
notation
then surely we must be following this
other rule also that the number of
pre-indices
denotes the order of the tensor of that
term
now if what happens if we if we apply
that rule
if we apply that rule then the number of
free indices here how many
zero because i here is repeated
there is no free index and that would
give us the impression that this entity
this
entire term is a tensor of order 0
but that is wrong you know that because
you you see ultimately what is this
representing it is representing
this vector but a vector we know is a
tensor of order 1
so what exactly is going on here you see
this kind of a notation as i said is
there is a little bit of an issue here
while writing like this
because it is neither pure index
notation
nor pure component notation okay i
repeat it is neither pure index notation
nor pure component notation
and that is where there is this kind of
a confusion you also note
that the moment we write like this
we are violating the very first rule of
index notation
which is that in index in pure index
notation
we should not be writing the the unit
vectors
but here you have the presence of the
unit vectors so it is some kind of a
hybrid notation the way that we have
written
it it is some kind of a hybrid notation
so if this is so very confusing why are
we even writing this
why not better stick to this kind of
thing where things are less confusing
well we are writing like this because as
you will see it will
certainly make our some of our
calculations and some of our initial
understanding
quite easy as we go along okay so
there is a certain advantage to it but
you realize that there is
a danger associated to it so let me just
point it out
that when you write some things like
this okay
so there is a little bit of a danger
associated with this so i'm drawing a
call here
associated here
okay we have to be careful here
okay so coming back to this now what i
want to do
is i want to carry out the dot product
okay of two to general vectors so
maybe the a vector and the b vector so
let's uh
let's try to do that
uh i'm taking up this very familiar
example of the dot product uh just to
show to you the the application of the
index notation
okay so we want to do
a vector dotted with b vector
and what i will do is
i will uh okay let me first write it out
completely in a very very easy to
understand
explicit way that this is
simply this
and this is
and you know that this is simply
a1 b1 plus a2 b2
plus a3 b3
we know this okay and you can very well
understand
that this is simply a i b i
okay the moment i write this a i b
i this is pure index notation there is
absolutely no problem with it
you understand that none of the rules of
index notation are violated here
we are not writing any summation sign
here there are no
unit vectors involved here there is no
free index
involved here there is only one repeated
index
uh the fact that there is no free index
present here means that this is a tensor
of order zero
which means that this is basically a
scalar quantity
and you all know for a fact uh even from
your high school studies
that the dot product of two vectors is a
scalar
quantity in fact the dot product another
alternative name of the dot product
is a is the scalar product
okay but uh in view of what we have been
studying
so let's see if we can approach the dot
product in a slightly different way
so again i am going to write this
but this time i will adopt the dangerous
notation
which i had just uh discussed so
what i am going to do is i am going to
adopt this this particular dangerous
notation
okay so we have to be a little bit
careful
so first of all i write like this that
a i e i that represents my
a vector this thing
must be dotted with the
b vector now the immediate temptation
is to write like d i e i
okay but you see my ultimate goal here
is to is to end up with some kind of a
valid
index notation okay i want to end up
with this particular result
but in a slightly more systematic
fashion and in order to do that
what i will do is i will not write like
this
okay i will so
even though my initial temptation is to
write like this but you see the problem
here
is that this i index the letter i
is repeated more than once repetition up
to here was fine
but here it is repeated more than once
in fact this is this is written
four times here so this doesn't make any
sense so instead of this thing
what i will do is i will uh
i'll correct this
and i will write it with a different
letter so
i'll write this as bj
ej hat now if i do that
you see here the ai is just like a
scalar component
okay it represents either one of these
a1 a2 a3s
similarly here the bj represents either
one of this b1 b2 b3s
so uh in terms of
the dot product that is taking place the
the real thing that is happening with
this dot product
is basically a game that is taking place
between the e i hat
and the e j hat those are the actual
vectors here
so we'll keep the dot with those things
and we'll take the
a i b j to one side
and we'll write like this a i hat e i
hat
dotted with e j hat now you note
quickly that we have already noted down
that this
e i hat dotted with e j hat that is
nothing but the chronicle delta
in the very next step we can write as a
i
b j delta i j
now there is only one step left and here
we are going to use something
extremely extremely useful which is to
take help of the substitution power
of the chronicle delta what is the
substitution power
you see whenever there is anything
multiplied with the chronicle delta
the kronecker delta itself has two
indices in this case
we have i and j now
you you think of this
of this thing multiplied with the bj
forget about the ai here
so when we say the substitution power of
chronicle delta what we mean is that
uh so let me just write down here
what i'm considering is bj delta ij
so this thing will be nothing but simply
bi so it is as if the result
of taking the product of this bg with
the delta i j
is that the index
which is not present here and but but
present in the kronecker delta which is
the i here
that gets substituted here so the j is
common here
that that j vanishes and this i get
substituted here so that is what is
happening here
okay so uh
this thing can be written as a i
bi now one may question
that here we have made the choice of bj
delta ij
okay but suppose we make the different
choice
that we write instead of this thing
we we consider the a i
delta i j then what will happen
now you see it is the index i which is
common
with the chronicle delta which means
that in the
this thing is going to be equal to a j
okay so the index which is not present
here is the j
index and that is in the result that j
index
comes here so this thing
is going to be equal to aj bj
now here i have written with an equal to
sign and you note
that if we just go go back and
check one of the rules of this index
notation
so a repeated index is like a dummy
index and it can be replaced by any
other letter
we have already written that a i b i is
perfectly equal to aj pj
and it is equal to anything else that is
that may be repeated
okay so what we have written here and
what we have obtained here using the
substitution power of the kronecker
delta that is actually being consistent
with
the rules of index notation so a i b is
very much equal to a j
b j and that is you understand is equal
to a 1 b 1 plus a 2 b 2 plus a 3 b 3
and you see this a i b i is exactly like
this ai b i which we had obtained
previously
so everything is nice and fine now the
way that we have proceeded here
even though we lived a little bit
dangerously when we wrote these terms
it is extremely useful when we are
carrying out
a higher order tensor operations as you
will see
okay in fact it makes our life a much
more
easy and we don't have to do any kind of
guesswork
it comes out very very systematically
that is the big advantage
of uh of using this thing okay
now to finish it off what we are going
to do is
we are going to represent the dot
product in terms of the matrix
representation
so let's do that on the next page uh
very quickly
uh you all know this uh
so a dotted with
d the matrix representation of that
will be
this thing so what i basically mean here
is that
this is equal to
a1 a2 a3
please note that this t it represents
the transpose
let me put the transpose here
so that this thing is equal to
we take the transpose of the column
matrix
it becomes the row matrix
and if we actually carry out the matrix
multiplication
what we obtain is exactly what
we had obtained earlier
a1b1 plus a2b2 plus a3 b3
uh you note quickly that without the use
of
this transpose this matrix
multiplication so if we if we had not
written this transpose
this matrix multiplication would have
been invalid in terms of the
order of the number of rows present okay
rows and columns present
okay so when we are carrying out matrix
multiplication the first one must have
the same number of columns
as the number of rows in the second one
so that thing gets violated without the
transpose
everything is nice and fine here so
that's how the matrix
representation is uh and this of course
is very much
equivalent to a i bi
okay so all these things the small small
things that we are writing
this will come in extremely handy uh
when we are
discussing the subsequent chapters uh
and and this particular thing is
especially useful in the kinematics
chapter and the
stress chapter uh that is the the next
two chapters
all right so with this will will uh
we'll close our
uh close this part of the lecture and
we'll continue with uh some other
operations involving vectors in the next
part of the lecture
thank you